david what's up brother how are we doing
hey john
uh i appreciate your work thank you good
man i appreciate you giving me a call
how can i help
so yeah my niece has been um saying
a lot of suicidal thoughts on her social
media
and talking to her closest cousins about
it
um me and my wife are currently on
military orders
in texas and my niece lives in new
jersey
i just i just want to know what can we
do from from here hmm
so when you say suicidal messages what's
what's she posting what's she putting up
so she has been posting um my wife found
her account on tick tock and she's been
posting things about
um her past with her bad relationship
with her father
um what do you mean by bad uh
so she two years ago
recently found out from her school that
from her father's side her
father's younger brother was sexually
assaulting her
for a few years and she recently came
out and
and confessed that who was a school
counselor in
uh two years ago um since then the
father took the brother's side
and pretty much is out of the picture of
her life is that brother in jail
um i think they're the case is pending
yes
well good i hope he goes to prison all
right so
um and so now she's living in the
aftermath what was dad's response
afterwards what was mom's response
afterwards
her her parents so her
her dad to one when they found out was
uh he didn't believe her um the mom
believed her and you know called the
cops and
and when they went to therapy and stuff
like that but the mom is not
i think her mom has had some troubles
too as well
um has a lot of mother issues and and
things like that
so so forget their moms and dads
personal issues how did they deal with
this young lady
so dad said i don't believe you didn't
happen until finally
he came around and believed that it did
uh no he
didn't really either he didn't believe
that it did he just kind of
he's not he's kind of a
one of those guys who are pretty much
like uh into drugs and um
running around in the streets and things
like that he's never been involved he's
a burnout okay
yeah yeah great great great father there
okay so you have this young lady how old
is she
she's 13. you have a 13 year old on
tick-tock and social media what is she
saying
so um the latest thing i saw was uh
her saying how sad she is how her mother
doesn't reach out to her talk to her
how when she went to counseling with the
state and all that
that they were just making her relive
what happened
they didn't seem like they even cared
about her um so it discourages
it's discouraging her from trying to get
help and then the latest thing
recently now is um she's asking what are
some
painless ways that she can
um kill herself i guess yeah
um not i guess when a 13 year old is
asking for
painless ways that's that's that's the
definition of crying for help
yes and that's what's really concerning
me yeah you should be super concerned
um when a dad doesn't believe his
daughter
when a mom doesn't comfort her daughter
when the whatever mental health
professional wasn't able to connect
there
yeah that's a recipe for disaster
and so what this young girl is doing is
using the only tools 13 year olds have
these days which is social media
right or wrong and she is screaming out
to the world somebody help
me and so who have you called
so my wife her is her
her is related to her mother um
we she does she doesn't have a great
relationship with her sister because uh
her sister
feels like my wife is always telling her
how
oh bickering at her or saying uh trying
to control her or something so
hold on hold on hold on i don't i i i
don't care
if i don't care anything about anybody's
relationships with anybody
what i'm asking you brother is who have
you called
so my wife called
um the only person that her sister
listens to
and she sat down and talked with her
sister and
she said she was going to get help with
her she said she was going to help her
uh get a counseling and things like that
but
um the way her sister is she's not one
to really follow through with it and
that's
where i feel really uneasy about it okay
good so
she will you know she won't right so
um here's the famous saying not by your
hand but in your lap
and this isn't something that you ask
for but you're a caring compassionate
guy
you clearly are about serving people
beyond yourself that's why you're in the
service while your wife in the service
you guys are are givers and servers and
so
i want to free you i want to free every
listener from any qualm any like
i don't know what to do next if you are
walking down the street and you see a
teenager
crying out for help if you have a third
cousin second removed
and their biological mom is in jail and
their biological dad was mean one time
at christmas and y'all haven't talked
for a few years
or in a messy situation like the one
you're in
i don't care i don't care i don't care
all that nonsense peels away brother and
you've got a
13 year old girl yelling in the only way
she knows how
saying help me please
mom doesn't count mom is doesn't work
she doesn't do anything
mom is not helpful she's not going to
follow through
daughter wouldn't be in this situation
daughter wouldn't be crying out for help
in these ways if mom was responding in
the right way
you know what that's not fair to even
say i'm not going to say that
that's not fair that happens um if mom
was
present there would be different
responses going on here
okay i understand so here's the deal you
call 9-1-1
you call local school you call the local
child protective services
you call everybody you can get their
number
yes okay and i don't care about the
relationship violation
i don't care if your wife's sister is
going to be
mad i don't care there's a 13 year old
good
girl saying help me please
yeah you know what i mean now i want to
tell you this one story okay
i worked in crisis for years this is
what i did
i showed up to suicide scenes i showed
up to
um shootings and car wrecks and i i
showed up to all kinds of different
situations and i also worked with young
people and college students for years
and years
and i remember a situation where a
couple of people all the same time told
me they were worried about a college
student
and i couldn't get a hold of them until
finally the the
young person texted me and said i want
you to know that you've been awesome
and something along the lines of i'll
see you on the other side or
take care something that made me it
wasn't a direct suicide threat but it
made me uncomfortable
so i did something weird that i don't
normally do i got in my car and just
drove to their house
this is an adult student the student was
25 or so as an adult student i drove to
their house knocked on the door and
their roommate was inside
the roommate said oh they're just
sleeping i said i want to see him with
my own eyes
so we went in their room they were
asleep the room looked real not good
man there was nothing on the walls there
was a couple of trash sacks it was just
a mattress on the floor there was a
bottle of pills by the bed
and there was a gun in the room and i
knew the room didn't look good
and i leaned down to talk to the student
they were snoring
in a really deep way and i leaned really
close
and i yelled as loud as i could nothing
yelled again
nothing and i just said man what
like they're clearly asleep right now
there's the bottle's still full of pills
you know i they're in texas they're
allowed to have guns right i mean
the math i was running through my head
for some strange reason and i've done
this over and over and over again
i couldn't make this one add up so i
called a friend of mine
and you talk about providential i called
my friend who was another
crisis responder and she happened to be
at
lunch with the number one college crisis
counselor
on the planet brian van brunt they're
having lunch together
and i'm walking her through here here's
what i'm looking at
and brian yells at the table i heard him
through the phone
what are you doing call 9-1-1 and i went
oh my gosh call 9-1-1 and i had gotten
so deep into the relationship part
the roommate was saying no man he just
sleeps really heavy man he snores like
crazy all the time he's fine he's just
sleeping
turns out he was in the middle of a
suicide attempt turns out he was
had been crying out for help and
i was somebody who does this for a
living and i was sitting right there and
i let all the other variables cloud
the one central judgment which was i
need to get this kid some help
right now and so i want to tell you that
to tell you this
i'm not judging you i'm not blaming you
i'm not mad at you
but at the end of this phone call one
somebody from my team is going to make a
call
because that's what we do yeah at the
end of this phone call
you need to get with your wife and y'all
rally up and before this
day is over probably before you have
lunch you got to start making some calls
to make sure this young girl's got some
adults in her area looking after her
because the adults who've been assigned
to her by god aren't showing up
and i want you to know i know that
there's a lot of relationship dynamics i
know there's a lot of this is in that
and so i want to help you the same way
brian and my friend help me cut through
all that stuff you got a 13 year old
girl saying please help me
and you need to get on the phone and
make those calls okay
sounds good yeah is that fair i
understand
completely yes and listen david i want
to commend you for being an uncle that
cares
i want to commend you for being a person
who loves his wife
and who sees something that's not right
and says i've got to get involved no
matter what
i've got to get involved no matter what
i just don't know the right thing to do
everybody listening to this here's the
right way to do it
you run out in the street with a pot and
a pan and you start banging them
together saying hey listen listen
somebody needs help
that's what you do and i hear people ask
like well what's my legal responsibility
what's my obligation
here's the deal when we start letting
the state or we start letting the
federal government define
our baseline for how we're going to
treat one another we're in a bad mess
churches schools workplaces
friends when our first thought is what
do i have to do
to care for somebody god help us man
god help us get involved
especially when it's a child
especially when it's a child who
suffered sexual abuse at the hands of
her brother
her dad turned his back on her and mom's
not showing up
get involved
brother david i am grateful for you man
i'm grateful for everybody out there
there are people out there right now who
have been thinking for a while should i
make that call i
i don't want to get involved i would
much
much rather make a call much rather make
a call and have someone be like dude
what's the matter with you i'm fine
i'd much rather that call than the one
that you don't make and then you find
out hey
i hate to break it to you but so and so
took their life
so and so is in an institution now make
the call